c'est donc la jeune femme ana ivanovic
qui a remporté le tournoi féminin de
roland-garros et un premier titre du
grand chelem qu'elle a décrochée en deux
sets face à la russe dinara safina 6 4 6
3 un bonheur qui n'arrive pas seul
puisque lundi ana ivanovic deviendra
officiellement numéro un mondial
alain dorgans et joy d'énergie ses yeux
remplis de bonheur sont ceux de anahid
anodine passation de pouvoir roland
garros justine henin jeune retraité
remet la coupe à la jeune serbe qu'elle
avait battu en finale l'an dernier la
finale de l'année dernière était une
très bonne leçon pour moi et je suis
vraiment eu tellement son ex à seulement
20 ans ana ivanovic remporte son premier
tournoi du grand chelem
un succès qui lui était promis dès l'âge
de 5 ans perpétuant la tradition des
joueuses mannequin programmés pour
gagner sa victime du jour
la russe dinara safina la soeur de marat
safin qui manifestement ne s'était pas
remis de sa débauche d'énergie dépensée
en quarts et en demi finale une bataille
de fond de court qui fait rage et du
haut de son mètre 85 ivanovic prend le
meilleur sur safina
sous le regard envieux de l'ex numéro un
mondiale amélie mauresmo mais la
moscovite ne s'avouent jamais battues
les missiles expédie du fond du court
feront tressaillir la jeune serbe
ivanovic résistent aux assauts répétés
de la rue renvoient toutes les balles et
son aptitude à varier le jeu fera le
reste
la russe effondré semble résigné
c'est incroyable je n'ai encore pas
réalisé on était tous les dossiers les
reçoit dans ce match et on avait tout
c'est de boxe à l'occasion je suis
tellement contenir jusqu'à la fin c'est
l'incroyable ana ivanovic s'impose en
deux sets secs
la nouvelle icône du tennis mondial a
imprégné de sa grâce roland garros elle
n'a pas fini de s'illustrer sur les
cours et dans les revues de mode et
demain